un mayor Promesa de campaña el
presidente Gustavo Petro firmó la ley
418 el marco jurídico de la paz total en
Colombia una tarea difícil para el jefe
de estado no solo para negociar con las
guerrillas como el eln pero también con
los grupos paramilitares la violencia en
Colombia afecta a muchas poblaciones
forzando la gente a huir de sus casas
aquí en el cauca los combatientes del Ln
y del Clan del Golfo se disputan a
sangre y fuego los poblados que bordean
la ruta para el tráfico de cocaína los
desplazados quieren la paz pero siguen
siendo realistas tenemos esperanza en el
nuevo presidente que ojalá pues cumpla y
prometa que no solamente es prometer hay
que prometer y hay que cumplir y es
mejor no prometer y cumplir preguntamos
al director ejecutivo del centro de
estudios en seguridad y paz en Colombia
Néstor rosanía si el gobierno de
petróleo iba a cumplir esta nueva ley
nos explicó que era un esfuerzo
necesario hacia la paz a pesar de su
pesimismo lo mismo pasó hace más de 30
años con el Cartel de Cali El Cartel de
Cali negocio con el gobierno y apareció
el cartel del Norte del Valle y una
nueva espiral de la violencia entonces
lo que vamos a tener Es que muchos
grupos armados irán negociará con el
gobierno Petro Pero los que están abajo
en la pirámide esos van a armar nuevos
grupos y va a seguir Cuál es el piso
esto el negocio de narcotráfico sobre el
narcotráfico Petro prometió un cambio de
paradigma quiere impulsar la sustitución
de cultivos ilícitos y prohibir la
dispersión aérea con glifosato pero la
multitud de los actores y la complejidad
del territorio podrían comprometer el
sueño de paz del nuevo gobierno de
Colombia